oh oh my gosh
let's go time is running out the most
stressful thing i've ever done
welcome to song lab a new show where we
bring three producers and three
musicians to pair up
to make an original song in only two
hours
the three teams will compete to make the
best song possible
and our followers will vote for the song
that they like the most the most voted
song will be the winner
and the winning team will win a cash
prize welcome
to song lab
[Music]
here we have three amazing producers and
three talented musicians
let's go around and introduce ourselves
to one another so you can have an idea
of who you might be working with
or competing against feeling like a
villain
hey guys my name is time service the
music i make mainly revolves around hip
hop so stuff like hip hop and trap so
anything kind of beat related
and now i'm wishing i could press race
my name is michaela
my artist name is dear evergreen i
predominantly make
vocal driven indie electronica
what's good people my name is ocean the
type of music that i usually make is
trap beats drill hip-hop
[Music]
lo-fi rmb bedroom pop
i go artistically by kind keith i make r
b
meal soul inspired music okay now that
we've gotten to know a little bit about
each
other let's figure out what are the
teams so
simon you're up first which number card
do you
choose give me number two please and
thank
[Music]
let's you dear evergreen michaela you're
up let's do three
which leaves our two folks from the uk
ocean and team uk
[Music]
let's find out what is the theme of the
song today
we asked our audience and followers for
theme suggestions and the most voted
theme
was falling out of love hey
yeah there we go and with that dean you
must incorporate these three words
into your lyrics for the song gone
stranger and loss you all have
two hours or 120 minutes to create an
original song with
fema falling out of love i'm super
excited to hear what you all come up
with
have fun and made the best song win
oh man how are you feeling right now
dude i was like pretty nervous but you
know what he said like
falling out of love song and then we can
just do a bunch of dash yeah
i know you're all about that
i'm a little bit of a perfectionist but
i definitely want to challenge myself in
this to
pick an idea and stick to it keep going
and then bounce back
what kind of vibe you feeling i'm just a
bit like
uh sorry i just feel really like
overwhelmed
we've got two hours i'm just getting
sounds ready i'm getting the rain
ambience oh you're already you're
already
i'm going right now just the idea of
losing a love i immediately came up with
like a little chord progression
you know what i don't think we have time
to hesitate yo you won't put the midi
down
i'm gonna link you a google drive folder
i don't know what the cash prize is but
i
want it dude no i feel that dude i'm
here
i'm here to win right now i'm going to
try hard right now
okay what are we doing this this sounds
like a
good intro let's put some echo on it
[Music]
something that i was thinking could be
cool is doing arps
oh that's nice and then okay with like
the falling idea
you are mad talented i can't even tell
you how happy it makes me to see more
and more female producers because we
need a lot of that in this music
industry especially
like how male dominant it is hell yes
amen
[Music]
yes yes yes yes that's the one that's
small oh you like that one
yeah yeah that's good all right cool i
just deleted that let me put that back
oh wait were you not feeling it i felt
like it was too low
okay i feel like i'm annoying him okay
um you're
always telling me
this is so hard oh you're gone
you're gone oh i like that i really like
that oh go on we can change the chord
there
[Music]
whoa
i like that i like that
there we go that's a solo
just vibing out over there
where did you go you're so
far gone
[Music]
okay reverb and echo oh my gosh you're
like a super woman
you've got the harder work than i do
because you're the producer and i feel
like that's so much
no i feel like songwriting with this
kind of pressure like i don't envy
[Music]
sound good when you sing do you usually
sing with autotune or do you just do it
like all dry i'm using a um harmonizer
thing
and it kind of pitches stuff for you
[Music]
my computer's like bugging out
check check check ooh i'm way too hot
chat chat chat chat you're always
telling me
inside your mind
[Music]
i'm so hyped up right now dude this is
exciting this song is sounding really
good
i'm i'm so curious what the other people
are going to do yo what is like one of
their sounds exactly like what we did
what's up guys how you guys doing hey
paula good good
we're under a lot of pressure because
we're like oh my god bro
we got this i'm so excited right now i'm
here to give you guys a challenge
just to make it a little bit harder your
team's challenge
is to incorporate a sample sound
to your song that was sent to us by one
of our followers
so please choose a number from
one two or three give me three
please and thank you
a fan turning on a fan let's do three
i can't hear you you're muted i was
saying do you want to do two but we can
do three if you want
wait would you say two yeah two is fine
let's do two
[Applause]
[Music]
do you want to go for it the sample is
going to affect you not me
let's go for one
all right we could try to do something
with that immediately
me and simon were both just like dude
this is like a percussive element this
is perfect like just throw that in the
intro
we'll be good
[Music]
i might just i might just put that in
the beat give it
a little bit of reverb let's do
some equalizing
i want to put a little bit of delay and
that's it
okay that's just a beautiful sounding
texture i'm actually kind of excited
about this random sample what i'm
thinking of doing
is plugging it into this synth called a
granulator
which basically chops up little sections
of it
and turning it into its own instrument
come on
yes
oh she's interesting
[Music]
this sample is actually really sick it's
just got like a very percussive element
i feel like i can chop this up turn it
into some drums
[Music]
we have like less than an hour to write
this song no we got this we got this
it's so calm
it's like really helping me the words
are kind of sad
i think we should flip it so it's kind
of like falling out of love but not in a
sad way it's like an empowering breakup
song type thing hello hello
did you get gone don't be a stranger
to me
[Music]
project's getting a little hefty now
this is where it gets tough do you want
to play yourself out with the outro
actually i don't think i have time i
gotta mix
okay yeah i can do that let's hit this i
think this might be one of the last
things i do
[Music]
i don't even know what i'm writing
do we only have 30 minutes left heck
yeah oh
time is running out time is running out
[Music]
right there okay all right so that
checks off gone stranger and lost
[Music]
we have 15 minutes left oh i didn't
realize that
oh my days i'm gonna have to rush these
drums and everything oh god it's
the vocal that you just sent me it's not
playing anything
oh boy it'd be cool if the pre-chorus or
the chorus had like some heavy auto-tune
yeah we have we have
six minutes walk past me
[Music]
like a stranger like a stranger
oh man i think that timing is a bit off
[Music]
uh i'm not getting the time in yeah
that is good you're amazing
you know what that's not even
complicated
i've literally got i've had one vest i'm
gonna make it what one verse anyway
and then cut it after the chorus
[Music]
guys i think that's gonna be time okay
wow that was like the fastest two hours
of my entire life
honestly that was so intense my asthma
started to act off
i am more than impressed with how it
came out in the end
it's so sick given the circumstances i
feel like we did
a killer job we did all right we did
okay we did
average yeah it's missing a few stuff a
few spicings
from being 100 honest i feel like ocean
did
an amazing job and i just wish i had
more time
hi everyone welcome back hope you were
able to
vibe off each other now we're going to
listen to each other's music
let's begin with team a simon
and kind keith
[Music]
crazy already flipping off oh god
yes wow
that bass is a madness as well
[Music]
lovely
this is such a vibe it's just nice and
chilly
and that bass is lovely as well
can't you just stay with me
[Music]
oh
this one's amazing i think we got a win
already
this one is amazing
[Music]
you're gone
in two hours yeah
i'm shook that's mad dude simon's a liz
that's the fl studio genius right there
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
oh they're wild
like room tone within the drum sound so
it just makes it sound
really nice
i love the analogy
[Music]
i love that sauce
sounds like a sexy iphone commercial
[Music]
cold that chorus the chorus
with the drop that's nuts and you're
only so baby
so good thanks guys
[Music]
hell yeah
oh oh jesus this is nice
[Music]
so much swing on the drums
oh my neck hurts
[Music]
me
vibes or vibes
i'm very excited i'm actually really
amazed that you guys did this in two
hours
we have now posted these to our
instagram and we're getting votes as we
speak from our followers
so we're gonna find out soon which one
of these three songs will be the winner
all the teams on this panel they were so
good team
b probably has the biggest chance of
winning they have like an
actual sick chorus for ocean and lila it
was a cool as hell song
the vibe that they captured was really
really amazing i love
team a's song and that's something i
would just listen to that's an actual
song like you could put that on spotify
it's gonna bang i love it team a is
gonna win
and now we're back now for the results
my arms are sweaty truly the winning
song for today's song lab
and the team that's going to win the
cash prize
is team c your song stranger was the
most voted
that's a dope song that's crazy
look how he was there stressing
did not see that coming at all i don't
know
i don't know how we did that i guess
that's the great thing about music it's
very subjective
what i wasn't really feeling or thinking
like very unfinished
people liked it i think my biggest
takeaway is to just be
a bit kinder to myself just go for it
and let down in that voice in your head
that says oh i don't know if this is
cool or i don't know if this is dope
collaborate with people because you get
to see the things that you can do
outside of your own box working remotely
i never did this before the distancing
shouldn't
stop us we can still create great art we
still create
wonderful music had a great time bye
thank you so much for watching that
first episode of song lab i hope you
liked it
if you love the songs that you heard you
can listen to the full length tracks
from each team
on the links below make sure to like
subscribe and share this video with your
friends
see you guys next time